i have to address an issue that came up
i've gotten a lot of notes about this on
youtube and twitter and all sorts of
places
the rapper tom mcdonald uh put out a hit
song i mean this thing is
number one on the charts it's getting
zillions of views on youtube it's called
snowflakes
and you know i'm not the most hip-hoppy
guy in the whole wide world but
it's uh it's an ironic sort of song
because it's in this
generally leftist medium of hip-hop but
it's very
uh right-wing in many of its talking
points talking about snowflakes you know
like the precious little snowflakes on
campuses
and i had a reaction to it we posted it
on youtube you can go check it out
but i i raised a question which was
the role of the woman you know these
these music videos tend to have
a woman or other women sort of dancing
around as the sex appeal
the woman in this video is played by a
man blaire white
who i like blair white has been on this
show he's a guy who identifies as a
woman
and he's relatively right-wing about it
if such a thing can be true he
he doesn't believe he doesn't say that
he's a woman he knows that he's always
going to be a man but he just says it
makes him feel better to
have these cosmetic surgeries and and to
present himself as
a woman in the world and i said you know
i'm glad
that tom's music video is one of the
biggest songs
on the planet right now i'd rather
people be listening to this
more right-wing rap than to this
to most left-wing rap whap or something
like that by cardi b
i'm glad that if people are going to
watch a transvestite they're watching
blair white who has generally more
right-wing things to say
then who knows the drag queens will go
on nickelodeon i'm glad about that
but but
isn't there a risk here isn't there a
risk that in our zeal to own the libs we
are actually adopting their premises
this was always the fear of the caitlyn
jenner candidacy
yeah maybe caitlyn bruce jenner would be
a better
governor than gavin newsom maybe
maybe he would maybe he would have
better policies sort of
but the cost of that would be the
embrace of the radical gender ideology
is it and what i've been told by people
who defend blair's appearance in this
music video or who defend the caitlyn
jenner candidacy
is michael you don't get it it totally
owns the libs
because the libs you see they think that
they've got a lock on all the
transgender
people but actually some of them are
conservative
and so yeah it's going to totally own
the libs to
to what to embrace their
radical vision and rewriting of of human
nature itself
that's going to own the i think that's
owning ourselves
i think that's a price if we keep owning
the libs like that there aren't going to
be any conservatives left
well no michael you can be transgender
and conservative
not really you can have this issue of
gender dysphoria and be conservative
you can struggle with this issue where
you're a man but you either very much
desire to be a woman or you think that
you're a woman or whatever people have a
lot of quirks right
you can but if you are
totally embracing this i'm not quite
sure you can be very conservative and
it's a threat to the broader
conservative vision
there have been people there was a woman
who wrote into me
and a woman of a certain age who says
she was a 62 year old mother who said
michael this is outrageous i like you we
don't agree on everything but your video
about blair white was so childish the
whole point was that a beautiful
trans woman does not agree with
snowflakes and their pronoun crap but
but
she does she goes by she and you're
you're calling her a woman
so not only is is blair going along with
it to some degree
but even worse the viewers are going
along with it
blair white is not trying to take the
place of a woman she's just trying to
live her best life okay well even you
know blair is
relatively quite grounded on these
issues
but you're referring to her but he is
not a she
the fear is forget even blair or bruce
jenner for a second
it's everybody else i know perfectly
conservative people who refer to caitlyn
jenner as she
or as caitlyn even i'm you know even i'm
doing it because it's very confusing
that's the fear that's the problem i
know that we all want to say yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes no we're the party of
yes to everything we're the biggest tent
in the world
well you know if the tent doesn't have
any tentpoles
anywhere if there are no limits no
demarcations then there is no such thing
as a conservative movement
just like if a nation doesn't have
borders it's not a nation a political
movement that has no boundaries
whatsoever
is not a political movement or it's a
completely impotent one like the
conservatives have been for decades at
this point
if we cannot at least put that tent pole
down and say
human nature is human nature
that we can't totally remake human
nature if we can't even say that we
can't
say anything at all there's a lot of
pressure to give in
on the racial questions on the sexual
questions
on the anti-american rights all the
radical critical race theory
there's so much pressure to give in and
say you know what white people are evil
america's a white supremacist country
it's hopelessly bigoted on the sexual
issues he has the patriarchy it's really
evil
head to rosis normative it's really evil
on the ante yes the founding fathers are
the worst people tear down the statues
there's so much pressure
you shouldn't give in hey before you
retire
and shut off all of your electronics so
that you can fully celebrate
the feast day the national feast day of
juneteenth the holiest day of the entire
liturgical calendar
according to the modern libs as of like
five minutes ago
before you do that subscribe ring that
bell
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcasts google play spotify
stitcher wherever you go
get the michael knowles show podcast
subscribe leave a five star review and
then most important of all
pre-order speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now
for pre-order head on over see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you